[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi
i'm holly black and i'm going to be
reading to you from a book i love very
very much
neil gaiman's coraline i'm going to be
reading chapter 10.
coraline walked up the stairs outside
the building to the topmost flat
where in her world the crazy old man
upstairs lived
she'd gone up there once with her real
mother when her mother was collecting
for charity
they had stood in the open doorway
waiting for the crazy old man with a big
mustache to find the envelope that
coraline's mother had left and the
flathead smelled of strange foods
and pipe tobacco an odd sharp cheesy
smelling thing scoreline could not name
she had not wanted to go any farther
inside than that
i'm an explorer said coraline out loud
but her words sounded muffled and dead
on the misty air
she had made it out of the cellar hadn't
she and she had
but if there was one thing that coraline
was certain of it was that
this flat would be worse she reached the
top of the house
the topmost flat had once been the attic
of the house but that was long ago
she knocked on the green painted door it
swung open
and she walked in
we have eyes and we have nerves we have
tails we have teeth
you'll all get what you deserves is
when we rise from underneath whispered
a dozen or more tiny voices in that dark
flat with the roof
so low where it met the walls that
coraline could almost reach up and touch
it
red eyes stared at her little pink feet
scurried away as she came close
darker shadows slipped through the
shadows at the edges of things
it smelled much worse in here than in
the real crazy old man's upstairs flat
that smelled of food unpleasant food to
coraline's mind
but she knew that was a matter of taste
she did not like spices
herbs or exotic things this place
smelled as if all the exotic foods in
the world had been left
out to go rotten little girl
said a wrestling voice in a far room
yes said coraline i'm not frightened she
told herself
and as she thought it she knew that it
was true there was nothing here that
framed her
these things even the thing in the
cellar were illusions
things made by the other mother in a
ghastly parody
of the real people and real things on
the other end of the corridor
she could not truly make anything
decided coraline
she could only twist and copy and
distort things
that already existed and then coraline
found herself wondering
why the other mother would have placed a
snow globe on the drawing room
mantelpiece
for the mantelpiece in coraline's world
was quite bare
as soon as she had asked herself the
question she realized there actually was
an
answer then the voice came again
and her train of thought was interrupted
come here little girl
i know what you want little girl it was
a rustling voice
scratchy and dry it made coraline think
of some kind of enormous
dead insect which was silly she knew how
could a dead thing
especially a dead insect have a voice
she walked
through several rooms with low slanting
ceilings until she came to the final
room
it was a bedroom and the other crazy old
man upstairs sat
at the far end of the room in the near
darkness bundled
up in his coat and hat as coraline
entered
he began to talk nothing's changed
little girl
he said his voice sounding like the
noise dry leaves make as they rustle
across a pavement
and what if you do everything you swore
you would
what then nothing's changed you'll go
home
you'll be bored you'll be ignored no one
will listen to you don't really listen
to you
you're too clever and too quiet for them
to understand
they don't even get your name right
stay here with us said the figure said
the voice from the figure at the end of
the room
we will listen to you and play with you
and
laugh with you your other mother will
build
whole worlds for you to explore and tear
them down every night when you are done
every day will be better and brighter
than the one that went before
remember the toy box how much better
would a world be built just like that
and all for you
and will there be gray wet days where i
just don't know what to do and there's
nothing to read or to watch and know
where to go and the day drags on forever
ask for a line for the shadows the man
said
never and will there be awful meals with
food made from recipes
with garlic and tarragon and broad beans
in
ask coraline every meal will be a thing
of
joy whispered the voice from under the
old man's hat
nothing will pass your lips that does
not entirely delight you
and could i have day glow green gloves
to wear and yellow wellington boots in
the shape of frogs asked coraline
frogs ducks rhinos octopuses
whatever you desire the world will be
built
new for you every morning if you stay
here
you can have whatever you want
coraline side you really don't
understand do you she said
i don't want whatever i want nobody does
not really what kind of fun would it be
if i just got everything i ever
wanted just like that it didn't mean
anything
but then i don't understand
said the whispery voice of course you
don't understand she said
raising the stone with a hole in it to
her eye you're just a bad copy she made
of the crazy old man upstairs
not even that anymore said the dead
whispery voice
there was a glow coming from the
raincoat of the man at about chest
height
through the hole in the stone the glow
twinkled and shown
blue white as any star she wished she
had a stick or something to poke him
with
she had no wish to get any closer to the
shadowy man at the end of the room
carline took a step closer to the man
and he fell apart
black rats leapt from the sleeves and
from under the coat and hat a score or
more of them
red eyes shining in the dark they
chittered and they fled
the coat fluttered and fell heavily to
the floor the hat rolled into one corner
of the room
coraline reached out one hand and pulled
the coat open
it was empty although it was greasy to
the touch
there was no sign of the final glass
marble in it
she scanned the room squinting through
the hole in the stone
and caught sight of something that
twinkled and burned like a star at floor
level by the doorway
it was being carried in the four paws of
the largest black rat
as she looked it slipped away the other
rats watched her from the corners of the
rooms as she ran
after it now rats can run faster than
people
especially over short distances but a
large
black rat holding a marble in its two
front paws is
no match for a determined girl even if
she is small for her age
moving at a run smaller black rats ran
back and forth across her path
trying to distract her but she ignored
them all keeping her eyes fixed on the
one with the marble who was heading
straight out of the flat toward the
front door
they reached the steps on the outside of
the building coraline had time to
observe that the house itself was
continuing to change
becoming less distinct and flattening
out even as she raced down the stairs
it reminded her of a photograph of a
house now now
now not the thing itself then she was
simply racing
palmell down the steps in pursuit of the
rat with no room in her mind for
anything else
certain she was gaining on it she was
running fast
too fast she discovered as she came to
the bottom of one flight of stairs and
her foot skidded and twisted
and she went crashing onto the concrete
landing
her left knee was scraped and skinned
and the palm of one hand she had thrown
out to stop herself
was a mess of scraped skin and grit it
hurt a little and it would she knew
soon hurt much more she picked the grit
out of her palm and climbed to her feet
and
as fast as she could knowing that she
had lost
and it was already too late she went
down to the final landing at the ground
level she looked around for the rat
but it was gone and the marble with it
her hand
stung where the skin had been scraped
and there was blood trickling down her
ripped pajama leg from her knee
it was as bad as the summer that her
mother had taken the training wheels of
coraline's bicycle
but then back then in with all the cat
cuts and scrapes
her knee had had scabs on top of scabs
she had had a feeling of achievement she
was learning
something doing something she had not
known how to do
now she felt nothing but cold loss she
had failed the ghost children
she had failed her parents she had
failed herself failed
everything she closed her eyes and
wished that the earth would swallow her
up
there was a cough she opened her eyes
and saw the rat
it was lying on the brick path at the
bottom of the stairs with a surprise
look on its face
which was now several inches away from
the rest of it its whiskers were stiff
its eyes were wide open its teeth
visible and yellow
and sharp a collar of wet blood
glistened at its neck
besides beside the decapitated rat a
smug expression on its face
was the black cat it rested one paw on
the gray glass marble
i think i once mentioned said the cat
that i don't like rats at the best of
times
it looked like you needed this one
however i hope you don't mind my getting
involved
i think said coraline trying to catch
her breath i think you may
have said something of the sort
the cat lifted its paw from the marble
which rolled toward coraline
she picked it up in her mind a final
voice whispered to her urgently
she has lied to you she will never give
you up
now she has you she will no more give
any of us up than change her nature
the hairs on the back of coraline's neck
prickled and coraline knew
that the girl's voice told the truth she
put the marble in her dressing gown
pocket with the others
she had all three marbles now all she
needed to do was find her parents
and coraline realized with surprise that
bit was easy
she knew exactly where her parents were
if she had stopped to think
she might have known where they were all
along the other mother could not create
she could only transform and twist and
change
the mantlepiece in the drawing room back
home was quite empty
but knowing that she knew something else
as well
the other mother she plans to break her
promise she won't let us go said
coraline
i wouldn't put it past or admitted the
cat like i said
there's no guarantee she'll play fair
and then he raised he said
hello did you see that what
look behind you said the cat the house
had flattened out even more
it no longer looked like a photograph
more like a drawing a crude
charcoal scribble of a house drawn on
gray paper
whatever's happening said coraline thank
you for helping with the rat
i suppose i'm almost there aren't i so
you go off into the mist or wherever you
go and i'll
well i hope i get to see you at home if
she lets me go home
the cat's fur was on end and its tail
was bristling like a chimney swoops
brush
what's wrong escore line they've gone
said the cat
they they just aren't there anymore the
way's in and out of this place
they just went flat is that bad
the cat lowered its tail swishing it
from side to side angrily
it made a low growling noise in the back
of its throat it walked in a circle
until it was facing away from coraline
and then it began to walk backwards
stiffly one step at a time until it was
pushing up against coraline's leg
she put down a hand to stroke it and
could feel how hard its heart was
beating
it was trembling like a dead leaf in a
storm
you'll be fine said coraline
everything's gonna be fine
i'll take you home the cat said nothing
come on cat said coraline she took a
step back toward the steps
but the cat stay stayed where it was
looking miserable and
oddly much smaller if the only way out
is past her
said coraline then that's the way we're
going to go
she went back to the cat bent down and
picked it up
the cat did not resist it simply
trembled she
supported its bottom with one hand
rested its front legs on her shoulders
the cat was heavy but not too heavy to
carry it licked the palm of her hand
where the blood from the scrape was
welling up
coraline walked up the stairs one step
at a time
heading back to her own flat she was
aware of the marbles clicking in her
pocket
aware of the stone with a hole in it
aware of the cat pressing itself against
her
she got to her front door now just a
small child
squirrel of a door and she pushed her
hand against it
half expecting that her hand would rip
through it revealing nothing behind it
but blackness
and a scattering of stars but the door
swung open
and coraline went through
you